Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Lauren
Boebert are now at war and it is getting
delightfully ugly. And we should all cheer this on
because the more fractured that MAGA Trumpism is,
the worse it is for the Republican Party.
HuffPost reporting. Marjorie Taylor GREENE and
Lauren Boebert get personal in a very public spat.
The extremist congresswoman from Georgia accused
her Colorado counterpart of, quote, high school
drama, writes Josephine Harvey for HuffPost. What
is this all about? This started because Boebert
criticized GREENE at the America Fest event
for backing House Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy for speaker. This, I believe,
is the moment that started. This hilarious fight.
Speaker 4: Someone who we all respect. Marjorie
Taylor GREENE says Kevin McCarthy is going to
be a great speaker. I guess you'll have to ask
Marjorie about that. I'm a fan of hers. I'm an
admirer. But it's not something we see the same,
Warren. Well, you know, I've been aligned
with Marjorie and accused of believing a lot
of the things that she believes in. I don't
believe in this. Just like I don't believe
in Russians. Are you are you a hard nosed laser
at all this? No, I'm just saying, we we need to
actually have an inside conversation and and
and make sure that these promises are there.
Speaker 1: Wow. So subsequent to this, Marjorie
Taylor GREENE took to Twitter to respond where
she put out a three tweet screed, starting
with, quote, I've supported and donated to
Lauren Boebert for President Trump has
supported and donated to Lauren Boebert.
Kevin McCarthy has supported and donated to
Lauren Boebert. She just barely came through
by 500 votes. So the argument there is, despite
all of our powerful support, she barely 1/2.
Quote, She gladly takes our money. But when she's
been asked, Lauren refuses to endorse President
Trump, she refuses to support Kevin McCarthy.
And she childishly threw me under the bus for a
cheap soundbite. Marjorie Taylor GREENE continuing
quote, The country is facing extremely difficult
times. Americans expect conservative fighters like
us to work together to save America. And that is
the only mission I'm 100% devoted to. Not high
school drama and media soundbites. Save America.
Defeat the Democrats. This is super interesting
because we've known about the wings of the
Republican Party, the pro-Trump and the
anti-Trump wing. We know about how Mitt
Romney and Adam Kinzinger and Liz Cheney are in
a different wing of the Republican Party than
the MAGA people. These are all MAGA people.
This is now a subsequent division within MAGA
Trumpism where you have the pro Kevin McCarthy
people and the anti Kevin McCarthy people. There
are a bunch of different reasons for this.
One of those reasons has been McCarthy's.
Less than total enthusiasm for some of the tactics
that Trump wanted used to try to steal an election
he didn't win in 2020. So this is a division
we should absolutely be encouraging. This can
only be bad for Trump and for Republicans.
As the 2024 primary gets going green and
boebert two of the most visible, prominent,
newish Trumpist figures. And for them to be
going at it is extraordinarily interesting
and potentially beneficial to the left.